l'université de tours était le moins
bien traités que les autres le débuter
et les oem d'indre-et-loire daniel la
baronne alerté hier la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur sur la
faiblesse des financements de l'état par
rapport à d'autres établissements 2000
euros par étudiant de différences par
exemple avec l'université de tours une
inégalité que dénonce depuis longtemps
eux aussi les syndicats d'enseignants
florent clavel l'université de tours
parmi les moins bien lotis de france le
constat est signé daniel la baronne
députés de la majorité mais néanmoins
lucide sur le manque de moyens alloués
par l'état aux étudiants tourangeau
exemple 5300 euros en moyenne par élève
à tour contre plus de 7300 à orléans
soit plus de 2000 euros d'écart si l'on
veut que l'université de tours continue
à rayonner continuer à offrir des
formations en lien avec les besoins de
notre passage de ville l'autre passe un
emploi il faut sans doute pour revoir
cette question de la dotation par
étudiant comment expliquer cette
différence dans un courrier adressé en
janvier à la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur frédéric vidal le président de
l'université pointe une augmentation
continue du nombre d'étudiants 26000 en
2015 contre 31 mille aujourd'hui soit
+16 % quand dans le même temps les aides
de l'état n'ont augmenté que de 7%
interpellé hier par le député la baronne
la ministre rappelle les investissements
à venir
l'université pourra conduire des
opérations de rénovation énergétique de
ses bâtiments pour un montant de près de
5 millions d'euros qui s'ajoutent aux
9,6 millions d'euros dans le cadre du
contrat de plan etat-région une réponse
liés à la modernisation des bâtiments
loin de satisfaire les syndicats
d'enseignants focaliser eux sur les
moyens humains
depuis quelques années les conditions
d'enseignement n'ont cessé de se
dégrader
aujourd'hui il n'est pas rare de faire
cours avec des groupes d'étudiants de
plus de 30 voire plus de 35 40 étudiants
dans certains cas là ce qui se traduit
nécessairement par des difficultés à
d'interaction de travail
de budget suffisant le nombre
d'enseignants titulaires a constamment
baissé au profit de statut précaire
universités estime aujourd'hui qu'il
faudrait une rallonge de 22 millions
d'euros pour retrouver des moyens
similaires à ceux de 2015